c'est dimanche dernier lors du grand
prix de bahreïn que le coureur
automobile romain grosjean a été victime
d'un terrible accident
[Musique]
des images de cette collision avec une
glissière de sécurité ont glacé le sang
des spectateurs par chance 28 secondes
seulement après l'accident
romain grosjean fait son apparition en
sortant des flammes ces images terribles
terrible hospitalisés pour des brûlures
aux mains et à la cheville le pilote est
un véritable miraculé
très vite ils donnent des nouvelles
rassurantes de son état de santé mais
seulement quelques jours après cet
accident qui aurait pu lui coûter la vie
romain grosjean parle déjà de son retour
sur circuit je ne désespère pas de
revenir à abu dhabi et de faire mon
dernier grand prix comme c'était prévu
parce que j'en ai envie
et c'est ce qu'il faut faire le grand
prix d'abou dhabi qui se déroulera le 13
décembre prochain à savoir dans moins de
dix jours
romain grosjean est avec nous merci
romain d'être avec toi punishement pour
au moins une bombe très très très très
peur pour toi bon à l'heure tu as l'air
en forme la tête à l'air bien la taille
n'est franchement je re te voir en tout
cas merci d'être avec nous encore une
main de mickey ça va mieux deux de
travail
quand on voit les images sont tous les
enfants et les a beaucoup revu les
images
tu les as beaucoup revu les images ou
pata voulez les revoir ou pas comprendre
ce qui s'était passé pour essayer
d'analyser
après je me souviens de touche
absolument pas perdu conscience à chaque
moment a été clés pour réussir à sortir
de cette voiture est ce que tu peux
raconter à nos téléspectateurs parce que
ceux qui connaissent pas bien
mine de rien voilà le la f1 se disent
mais comment on peut s'en sortir d'un
accident comme ça ça s'est joué à
quelques secondes à un romain win s'est
joué à quelques secondes puisque plus
plus on avançait plus faire entrer dans
la voiture après lui la chance qu'un
pompier viennent et essaient de créer un
peu un corridor d'air pour moi que l'on
voit le médecin qui est venu m'aider sur
la fin et après surtout d'avoir gardé le
calme dans la voiture je pense que c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a sauvé la vie
c'est d'essayer de j'étais bloqué par le
rail de sécurité qui est au dessus de ma
tête ça donc au début j'ai essayé de
sortir j'ai pas réussi j'ai sa droite du
port ici j'essaie à gauche c'est pas
réussi après cette phase
j'ai eu beaucoup d'écrits tout où j'ai
cru que j'étais mort s'était terminée
que j'avais brûlé et puis il ya cette
dernière tentative vraiment j'arrive à a
tourné la tête sur la gauche a glissé
j'avais encore le pied coincé dans la
voiture donc fait la folie du me rassois
que je retire ma jambe pour arracher mon
pied et que je ressorte mais une fois
que les épaules était sorti de ça je
savais que j'allais vivre et que voilà
j'avais les mains qui brûlait j'en étais
conscient
ça faisait mal mais le prix à ces deux
prêts à payer pour vivre et c'était rien
du tout mais est robin et et tous ici où
on entend tout témoignage moi je bois
tes paroles vraiment cessé ses
incroyables et romain surtout c'est vrai
que moi je me dis ça s'est joué là tu
raconte toute l'histoire on a
l'impression que ça a duré longtemps
mais ça a duré quelques secondes
ta [ __ ] a dû essayer de dés et de sortir
surtout je comprends pas moi comment tu
as pu faire pour garder ton calme parce
que là tu t'es vu quand même partir oui
oui il ya un moment très compliqué avec
avec une rencontre j'avais pas que
c'était très proche à manger beaucoup
trop près de la mort après comment j'ai
gardé mon calme je sais pas c'est un
instinct de survie est ce qu'on est avec
ace concret j'aimerais essayer de
comprendre pour justement on puisse
éduquer les futurs pilotes pour qu'on
apprenne de cette situation on a appris
de tous les grands accidents et
aujourd'hui sa décision en vie c'est
notamment grâce à jules bianchi à
l'invention du halo qui est de la
protection qu'on a maintenant tu du la
protection vous avez il paraît que tu
étais pas pour à la base non plus à
l'époque
ah non j'ai été 100% contre j'étais 100%
contre et qu'est-ce que j'étais con à ce
moment là aujourd'hui je remonte pas
dans une voiture sans à l'eau c'est
incroyable et héros mince moi ça m'a ça
m'a fait marrer et je me suis dit romain
c'est quand même un gars exceptionnel
quand a dit le premier truc que tu as
dit dans cette interview c'est le halo
dire que j'étais pas pour ces samassa
m'a sauvé la vie
tu l'avouer tout de suite oui les
nicolas pernikoff et oui j'aimerais
comprendre quelque chose vous avez été
expulsé vous êtes resté sur le bout de
deux voitures de devant là je crois je
sais ce que je ne comprends pas vous
être resté sur le bund sièges avant
c'est ça enfin qu' on a ce qu'on appelle
la coque de survie qui est là où on
s'assied salle est restée intacte plus
ou moins intacte tirait mais elle aussi
sait où il ya le réservoir d'essence
la partie qui brûlent qu'on voit à
travers le rail
c'est l'avant de la voiture et c'est là
où il ya le siège effectivement c'est là
où j'étais bloqué robin on est très
heureux de vous voir aujourd'hui et au
moi je pense à votre dernière
déclaration qui vous dit je veux je veux
y retourner
je veux faire le grand prix d'abou dhabi
comment comment ont réagi vos proches
votre femme marion marion et qui a
l'amour qu'on connaît bien voilà que les
téléspectateurs connaissent bien comment
la régie qu'on vous lui avez dit ça
s'appelle tous mes proches ont mal réagi
au début et je les comprends
comment comment c'est possible et je
leur ai dit dès dimanche soir c'est ça
qui était fou je leur ai dit je veux ici
de rentrer de retourner à abou dhabi si
ça se fait tant mieux si ça se fait pas
c'est pas grave on trouvera on trouvera
d'autres solutions pour rebooter
peut-être une formule 1 mais c'est vrai
que j'aimerais que j'aimerais que ça se
passe parce que j'ai plein de trucs
spéciaux prévus pour mon dernier grand
prix en formule 1 et puis j'aimerais
leur c'était prévu en tout cas on est en
opération récupération n'écoute les
médecins tous les jours et puis on voit
qu'elles le sont les avis roman vous
êtes papa de deux garçons et d'une fille
vous avez pensé à eux quand vous êtes
sorti d'affaires c'est ce qu'ils m'ont
donné la force de sortir d'affaires au
moment où où j'ai cru que j'allais
mourir j'ai commencé à me demander par
quelle partie jallet brûlé et si ça
l'est toujours eu ou pas j'ai pensé à
mes trois enfants et je me suis dit
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
que je les laisse c'est pas parce qu'ils
aillent plus de papas donc j'ai retrouvé
ces derniers moments de d'énergie et
lucidité de décès de glisser mon casque
sur le côté et de remonter comme ça un
petit peu a entravé en tournant les
épaules et c'est comme ça que j'ai
réussi à le bloquer vous avez une
appréhension de retourner dans une
formule 1 ou pas du tout je ne sais pas
et et c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
j'aimerais monter dans la voiture
alors je suis allé à la piste déjà j'ai
regardé la voiture jaga des cockpits ça
m'a pas fait d'effets spéciale donc
peut-être demain je donnerais aux
circuits jma serré dans la voiture pour
voir ce que ça donne mais je pense pas
que non je pense pas que tu traumatisé
pour ça que j'ai envie d'essayer
romain en tout cas je vous souhaite un
très bon rétablissement vous êtes un
immense champion et on a eu très peur
pour vous embrassiez tout
famille et voilà je vous fais des normes
bisous et j'espère vous revoir sur les
circuits très vite et peut-être à abou
dhabi j'espère en tout cas merci romain
d'avoir été avec nous
[Applaudissements]